thank questions fan fan questions fan
questions
fan fan question - feigning all these
ready for attention he's gonna say
they're in ask us a question for oh
hello man oh hello hello hi hello hi in
question number 1 and where are you from
I'm from San Diego my name is Xavier I'm
a huge huge fan
my question is Javier anyone who can
answer it is there any plans to do
anything with the fact that booth is a
descendant of John Wilkes Booth well no
he's really very touchy about it and
it's been mentioned here and there but
was there any plans to do anything with
that John and Michael watch the
lumberjack I know some you'll find out
the lumberjack episode odd night for
Avery and maybe we can do more with it I
think what a lot of it was done in the
presidential assassination episode this
year but it is a good point maybe we can
figure something out fan questions fan
questions in the middle this side to me
if you can build an Angela Tron you can
build a time machine David you go back
to 1865 and stop that happened there you
go
fan questions hey thank you for your
question hi hi hi welcome thank you my
name is patty I'm from San Diego handle
daddy what's my question I understand
it's not that common that a show knows
so far in advance that it's going to be
ending and I'm wondering if people have
been coming out with let's fit this in
before then any passion projects or
ideas and this is for anybody to answer
thank you for that they mean ideas of
things or people to add to the 12
episodes yes well I've already pitched
that Cam's
the fire thrower or sword swallower
that's just Wow not fire here though
yeah fire throwers throwing fire not
throwing fire throwing fire and
swallowing swords that's that kind of
fairy yeah still time just don't throw
the fire at us twelve episodes I would
like to find a body under an ice rink
that's completely melted and what's
wrong with the Flyers I love them I mean
I got a I had more more hockey sorry I
know everybody down a few I feel like
we've done like 50% of oh I know I know
I know I know I've always wanted to do a
demolition derby episode remember
demolition derbies right okay member
Laverne Shirley what I was happy days
they did and Fonzie got crushed in the
car big arc they regional had a
condemned a listen Derby Day right like
like I'm driving the mawashi crunch who
doesn't remember that that's the bet was
like the best scene ever mulashi crunch
television history buck and Wanda are
back demolition derby she's got like a
car what's got bones on it I'll make her
partner in like a cop car undercover of
course hey that's my is she under hey
what about you
you know when we started this we had no
idea it would go as long as it did and
every year we never necessarily knew we
were going to get picked up and it's
because of everyone watching that we
were able to do that for 12 seasons and
the fact that Fox said we're going to be
12 more to really end it nicely and give
your fans one last hurrah so thank you
all for watching and I think the next 12
we're just excited to be able to say
goodbye the right way
Vijay you know how to work their hearts
god bless you
same question the next question question
Bank questions man question questions
and who are you hi my name is Jen I'm
from Huntsville Alabama Oh fun
not with an diego flew all the way in I
did yes oh it's welcome thank you do you
have a drink on the plane uh more than
one really yeah how old are you old
enough what a great great answer from
the fame this is exciting
oh I'm so excite what's your question
alright my question for you is each of
you have invested so much into your
respective characters over the past
decade how has your character influenced
your personal life in turn oh well let's
go down the line I'm starting to go get
me I don't where we're on down there I
go this way cuz I feel like we go down
this line and no one gets to talk from
that let's go down there and start there
John you're up you're gonna start with
me have you been eating a lot John and
your personal life yours Oh character
affected me personally ooh
I mean I got it you can talk about the
binge eating you can talk about it's
safe space
look III think it's just prepared me to
show up you know in any situation and
kind of I mean the funnest thing about
doing this show is you don't know what
anyone's gonna do next you know there's
a reason that's been on this long as
they know how to bring something new and
fresh so if anything is just given it's
changed me in that way it's just
prepared me for that you know right
answer I thought all of that
food-related
ah man um I think I just become more
bossy
I have my own life I feel like I'm the
boss of everywhere I go and I'm pretty I
feel pretty good about that
so um I think I think I was probably
always a pretty honest person but I
think Angela is a real you know direct
honest individual so I think over the
years
that's definitely sunken more and it's
definitely like my favorite quality of
her so I would say that I've always
hated bugs always and I still don't like
them that much but I know a lot more
about them are you like okay um well I
not from Alabama and I did not have a
drink but I am old enough to have one I
would say Wow
can I think about that for a little bit
how about my socks look booth area David
both wear the same socks very excited
about that
no when you go on a trip the first thing
you're supposed to do is change your
socks when you get off the plane and
because it helps with your jet lag did
you know that okay try this next time
you fly he does work and you know what
you may have had one too many drinks so
you may not find your socks it shouldn't
but trust me just put a pair in your
pocket you'll be good to go so I would
say socks really good answer you I would
say sometimes I'm I guess I've always
been a little bit of a rule follower but
Brendon makes me even more so that or
I'll say my husband will say I'm like
talking like Brendan will say like well
statistically that's not true ah
scientifically that's not proven so are
you know that kind of stuff where I'm
stickler for
facts I guess is a way that Brennan has
rubbed off on me
nice mm-hmm good facts you're like the
fat lady your facts we belong at a shark
a lightning one that's good facts about
backpacked seem facts fan questions
thank you thank you
do we have any squints in the audience
is Eugene here by any chance
no I see where what where is it
Eugene come up here you here get Eugene
up here now please
Thank You Eugene for Series appearance
ladies and gentlemen a man coming down
the middle come up here he is this is
the man is a squint best known area is a
wrecking machine okay assistant you talk
about killing off one of the recurring
characters being the original we
original recurring squid come out
these are fan questions oh well I'm
gonna ask it and I'm gonna stand right
here you are you work on the show still
a fan fan fan question the dose oh yeah
I'm coming help her with her question
mr. question um first of all I want to
thank you guys for hitting hard topics I
got diagnosed with cancer the same week
that Wendell no and it was really
inspiring because I did beat it and so
today also gay Randall
and you totally throw me off okay my
question was of all the interns that
have come through on the platform who do
you think had the best shot at getting
the full-time job I can answer that
right now I got a full-time job look at
that part
Clark Edison So You Think You Can Dance
we is anybody else here oh my god pass
here Clark I think some other people
work on the show here that you genius
tale again our Millah Kato part of the
laughs go the right get up here now he's
got credentials bring them up here
please hey let's go to the next question
thank you fan questions oh here we go hi
hi my name is Abby and I live in Arizona
and yeah welcome welcome Gabby um I have
a question for David yes I'm right here
I'm right here president I am here for
you what do you need Abby do you ever
miss angel or Buffy hey this took a turn
what a great fan question I thank you
Abby for coming I really thought that
was a really well thought out question
first of all I do you know when you work
on a show that had such an amazing
energy and cult following as Buffy did
with Joss and obviously went on with
David Greenwald and the people and the
writers get that show you always go back
and you remember those moments in those
memories so I would say that it lives
with me and I think I love the process
and I know you know it just is great so
here we are Abby and thank you for
joining us Emily
Eugene's bad I'm bad thank you for that
yes I do
do you remember working with you your
name TJ thine on Angel you got me a cup
of coffee
now we own lawyer lawyer right that was
a time word I don't remember the early
days Hodgins and booth I remember but
you know it was that was long ago was
now a fan question he worked a lot of
nights on those shows didn't I know you
think Dave you know Empire goes out in
the daytime what's gonna happen he's
gonna explode so I would say yeah what a
nice long nights don't have a weekend
just kept going so maybe you don't miss
that part of that job
actually I do is I'm kind of a night guy
are you yeah I have a tracks in my car
don't laugh have an eight-track a track
system forget digital I'm all big
8-track stuffing in BAM down the highway
66 babe let's roll so route while you're
not school all right you're back all
right next question
all right um I'm Kristin from Columbus
Ohio good baby
you have a magic halo across your
forehead I do what does that represent
I'm just like Pocahontas your back
where's your sphere it's in the car they
wouldn't let me bring it in great did
you cook did you arrive in a boat no not
at all you should leave in a boat I'll
get on one of those yachts in the back
very nice yeah that's gonna take a while
you're gonna take a big paddle for that
so I'm also team angel loved you ever
since Buffy um so do you guys have any
plans for after the show is done you
know maybe getting back together with
Joss and chair and Michelle Gellar just
an idea but really any of you guys do
you have an idea of what some of you
guys are gonna do I think all of us here
together are gonna do a spinoff
okay guys what characters would you play
let's go start down the line Oh John
Who am I you guys are Joss Whedon
spin-off oh man start on that side yeah
way to reprise my role as Hodgins I like
that
what did you play again what did you go
I was his lawyer oh you know lawyer gala
can I can I pass on my class oh you'd be
like can't I play Buffy you can you can
play Buffy no I would never do that I
can't fill those shoes how about you um
oh I don't know I don't know what show
is everyone did such a great being on
it's a spinoff so we have a few
characters that were meeting basically
new characters and Pocahontas arrived
and gave us this question okay and so
it's obscene off in a puffy ask spin-off
from Josh and we're all in it okay okay
so what would you be I don't want to be
human I'd like to be something from
another realm I don't know some evil
demon maybe maybe I think that could be
good
yeah what's your question so any idea
David's a pretty unique guy you don't
say what's your favorite I guess like
David ISM like besides in the way he
says bullet bullet cool it it's called
bullet a bullet um David likes to be the
person to say the last thing in the
scene David or Dave or last for Jones
last word dad for Jones for Jones class
for Dave um your back is then your back
your top shelf back top shelf top shell
pots and pick with a um a box of bands
you're Bob it's really crazy bouquet on
and on and never really it is its own
language
it's its own language that shouldn't
really exist pots and pans that's bark
I'm in fact something I don't know it's
really busy and strange and then you
also do that salty getting it you know
you do that thing to get anything I can
do all right
I hope you got the answer that you can
next question please
hi man go ahead hi oh oh sudden fan
question became fan audition she's back
okay
hi um I was curious I'm gonna miss the
show I love you guys by the way huh I'm
gonna miss the show so much so I was
curious what you guys are gonna miss the
most about being with this family in
this cast 24/7
um I don't make us come oh it's all over
I would say it's people that we work
with I mean we get to work with so many
awesome people from you know the writers
and showrunners to the other actors in
the the whole crew I mean we have a
great amazing group of people and it's
just been such a wonderful and missing
the characters I'm gonna miss Brennan
and I just I love all these people up
here they affect you they believe in you
they support each other and it's such a
great environment to be a part of I was
blessed to meet these people and they've
gotten me through lots of stuff in my
life and I thank them for their making
me humble and believing and I I just
like we went to war when we started this
we're going to come out the flag high
and we're just going to keep going and
share those memories and I love them all
like you missed Eugene again you know
right now you're gonna miss me you're
gonna try to follow that teaching the
what will we met the the end between us
what you don't get to see the behind the
scenes conversations the behind the
scenes laughter and support for each
other but that's what I'll miss the most
yeah
the messing up of lines and you know the
technical line all of the laughter that
goes on with not knowing lines or the
giggle okay the giggle twins yeah I
would say that big giggle yeah yeah I
think that does the same goes for me I
think the laughter the laughter you know
ten years of laughter is a pretty damn
healing and yeah so I'm gonna miss these
guys not yet though we've got 12
episodes Johnny how about you oh I think
I'm just gonna miss the the graciousness
of you know one of the best legendary TV
casts ever anims
thank you guys so much for letting me
join in here yeah congratulations
Eugene you guys can give your thoughts
on this come on I came on two bones in
season seven I was very lucky and I am I
jumped on to this functional wonderful
family and it took me in it I couldn't
be more grateful and I can't tell you
how much you're gonna miss it it's um
it's a part of me now no it's a unique
environment I started as a staff writer
and there's not a lot of shows where
that can happen where you can go from
staff runner to showrunner and Hart and
everybody here just really built a
culture where they helped you to grow
and depreciate we've had you know
hundreds of babies that have been born
on the show in the time that we've been
around and it really it's it's amazing
the the family and the culture that is
there and so I I can't imagine life
without it so I'm in denial I don't
think it's gonna end but I get a will
but I don't want to believe it
it all started so hard to hear the David
thought that Michael said he started out
as a saxophone player said of a staff
writer that I heard just great as
someone who made the mistake of leaving
I can actually tell you what it feels
like leave bones I miss the family this
was such a wonderful family to work with
and he's not here tonight but Hart
Hanson
and also Stephen Nathan the fathers of
this family they created something
really wonderful and in 35 years of this
business I've never experienced anything
quite like it
this has been just the most wonderful
show I agree and it's so hard because
there's so many people that are involved
I mean Kathy Reichs
Barry Josephson people that brought here
Fox for continuously to support us on
the network and the studios all of the
people that do the marketing the
publicity you know I mean let's the list
goes on and on and if you don't mention
them Bobby Altman I mean you you tend to
forget Jan de Wit who is no one knows
really about who Jan do it is and he's
seen me the show happen yeah I mean
these guys an Ian Titan who is just was
always there for us so there's so many
people and if we forget you we apologize
so don't get upset way
hours then you know yeah we will show
credits then yeah the thing is that
what's so special about this particular
show is that I came in in season three
sort of as a replacement for Zack in the
beginning and I've done a lot of shows
over the years and it's hard to just
jump into a show but it was one of the
most welcoming casts I've ever been a
part of I've got great friendships from
this impatient Michael a lot of people
know that the people up here you you
couldn't have asked for a greater - with
Emily and David um they set the tone and
they make everything right so this is a
family and it's hard to say goodbye but
all good things must come to an end
that's awesome all right I think we
probably have time for one or two more
questions like more bang
I think it's great bad questions hi my
name is Micah and I'm from San Diego
we're not finished singing you guys said
to interrupt you I'm out fan question
Bank questions yes fan questions so
please David you're making rush so
beautiful great job hey what's your
quite as quick my question is for John
me we are not done okay we are done
because we gotta go now but honestly you
have you have no FBI stuff on what's
going on no she can't look over at that
she knows where your back location your
own best outfit ever thank you thanks go
ahead my question is for John given the
amount of eating that Aubrey does on
camera how do you stay in shape and are
not more really using no pressure no you
broke it all up course that's not a
that's a tear no so the eating is um
it's my responsibility
see see seriously the um the line
between being grossed out by a dead body
and being excited by it is kind of a
similar thing to all Gurian food so it's
kind of nasty but it's just so good that
you can't stop dude you eating
cheeseburgers over and over I am
sandwiches or doughnuts at the same time
it's just not right
it's just you have that spit bucket
don't you no I don't use the spit bucket
oh and then what's a bucket oh that's
for me sorry you can call you know my
approach of that stuff is just you know
I'm game to do whatever and it's fun to
you know see what they throw at me and
we always just you know I just eat it
like that's what what can you like say
yes to gold fries bad pancakes old
barbecue mmm anyway okay thing one more
question
oh we got more fan question question oh
yeah we're gonna have a fan question
time we're gonna get to the question I'm
not going to answer what a sing like
enzymes hi fan question hi I'm Cassidy
from Oceanside
fine motion see thank you did you arrive
at höganäs no sorry
you just got to plow through when they
go ahead ask again my question is what
was your favorite part of this Sleepy
Hollow crossover episodes it's fun to
work with other actors in another show
and having to put two different worlds
together which I know must have been not
a small feat for the writers to do um
but it's always fun to meet you know
people even met producers and actors
from the other show so those fun that
was fun I don't know
Hodgins actually said to Angela at one
point I got to get home and record
Sleepy Hollow so was a little weird for
me when we actually crossed affirm her
because he's a fan of the show so but we
just decided to kind of jump over that
okay unfortunately we have run out of
time wait one more fan question I won't
sing how long stay go ahead quick um
this is for david i noticed that you
have a stealer coffee mug on your desk
every show and I'm a die-hard Steeler
fan and I just want to know if you are
too well when the show first started
there was a like I have a lot of props
that have certain specific meanings oh
and there's one point where I was like
you know maybe booth because I like the
Steelers I used to be a ball boy for the
Steelers great family the steel the
Rooneys and at one point I wanted to get
a Jack Lambert Jersey maybe put that up
and then it just shifted so I had to put
something from Pittsburgh with the
Steelers only only Pittsburgh Steelers
that's it that's all I would go to
you